what's interesting is the presumption in
the United States is that it's you know
terrible to be an asset of Russia but
entirely acceptable to be an asset of
Ukraine and and many of course in
Washington are the president's own son
worked for Ukrainian company and the
president himself was deeply enmatched
in the internal politics of Ukraine when
he was vice president and of course
until today
um and I'm not sure why that's better
you know no one in the United States
ought to be an agent of a foreign power
or promoting foreign interest at the
expense of American interests I mean in
a democracy it's very simple the
government exists to serve the people
who put it in power by voting
and your foreign policy ought to reflect
that which is to say your foreign policy
ought to serve the interests of the
country